this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lung cancer this
video will help you understand some of
the available treatment options
lung cancer is a disease in which cancer
cells form in lung tissues
the two main types of lung cancer are
non-small cell lung cancer and small
cell lung cancer
non-small cell lung cancer has several
treatment options
surgery
radiation therapy chemotherapy
targeted therapy immunotherapy
laser therapy
photodynamic therapy
cryotherapy
electrocautery and watchful weighting
there are several types of surgery
depending on the size and location of
your tumor and how well your lungs are
working
during one type of surgery called wedge
resection surgery a small piece of a
lung is removed
in another type of surgery called a
lobectomy a larger piece of the lung
called a lobe is removed
during a pneumonectomy an entire lung is
removed
and in a sleeve resection your doctor
may remove a part of your bronchus if
cancer is in your airway
another treatment option is radiation
therapy it uses radiation to kill cancer
cells or stop them from growing
external radiation therapy uses a
machine that aims radiation at the
cancer from outside the body
internal radiation therapy uses a
substance that gives off radiation
the substance is put inside the body
near the cancer
chemotherapy fights cancer by using
drugs
these drugs may treat the whole body
or they may treat one area
targeted therapy uses drugs that target
specific cancer cells
these drugs prevent the cancer cells
from growing and dividing
since these drugs mainly affect the
cancer cells there's less damage to your
normal cells
immuno oncology also known as
immunotherapy helps your immune system
fight cancer
cancer can sometimes hide from the
immune cells that attack them
for example cancer and immune cells may
have proteins called checkpoint proteins
when they attach attack from other
immune cells is stopped
some immunotherapy drugs for lung cancer
block the checkpoint proteins from
attaching to each other
as a result the immune cell can attack
and destroy the cancer cell
in laser therapy an intense beam of
light burns cancer tissue
photodynamic therapy uses a
light-activated drug
once the drug enters the body
it collects in cancer cells
then fiber optic tubes are put into the
body near the tumor
laser light is sent through tubes
the light activates the drug
the activated drug then kills cancer
cells
during cryotherapy cancer tissue is
frozen and destroyed
in electrocautery a heated instrument
destroys cancer tissue by burning it
and lastly watchful waiting is done in
certain cases of non-small cell lung
cancer your doctor closely monitors your
condition until symptoms appear or
change
the main treatment options for small
cell lung cancer are two of the same
ones used to treat non-small cell lung
cancer chemotherapy and radiation
therapy
for either type of lung cancer your
doctor may prescribe a combination of
treatments
if you have questions about lung cancer
or any medications you have been
prescribed talk to your doctor it is
important to take your medications as
directed and report any side effects you
have